[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So let's
continue with our discussion
of the derivative.
Let me recall that the
derivative of a function, if it
exists, which we denote
by f prime of c, this
is the limit as x
goes to c of f of x
minus f of c over x minus c.
Last time, we looked at the
relationship between continuity
and differentiability and showed
that differentiability implies
continuity, but that
having a derivative
is quite a miraculous thing.
Because there are
continuous functions,
which we actually constructed.
We constructed a
continuous function.
You can generalize that example.
So we constructed a
continuous function
that is differentiable nowhere.
So in fact, differentiability
is a much stronger condition
than continuity.
And it's something of a miracle.
Just as a side note, if you go
on to study complex analysis,
which are functions
of a complex variable
rather than of a real
variable, you also
have the notion of
a derivative there.
And then, the derivative
is much more miraculous
than it is here in
the setting of r.
But the whole point
is, the derivative
is something of a miracle.
So today, the goal is
to prove some properties
about the derivatives.
Most of these you know.
Maybe you didn't cover
the proofs of them
in calculus with the ultimate
goal of proving the mean value
theorem, which
is, to me probably
the most underappreciated
but most important
result in calculus.
Now, you could
argue that probably
the hero of the
story of calculus
is the fundamental
theorem of calculus, which
connects integration,
which we'll cover next
after differentiation.
Which so the fundamental
theorem of calculus
connects integration
and differentiation.
So that really is, but--
and that is really
the hero of calculus.
It gets used more
than anything else.
But to prove that, you use
the mean value theorem.
So if the fundamental theorem
of calculus was Batman,
I would say the
mean value theorem
is something like Alfred.
He's really the reason why
Batman gets to be who he is.
Enough analogies for now.
Let's go back to proving some
properties of the derivative.
So first, let's do some basic--
the basic linearity and
rules for the derivative.
So let f go from I to R.
i is always some interval.
And if f-- so I have
two functions, f and g,
from I to R. c is a point in i.
And the conclusion is, if f
and g are differentiable at c,
then we have several
rules that we can apply.
The first is basically the
linearity of the derivative
that for all alpha and
R, function alpha f plus
g, which now goes from I to
R, is differentiable at c.
And the derivative of the
function alpha f plus g
prime c is alpha times f
prime of c plus g prime of c.
I think I'm starting to write
a little slandered here.
Second is the multiplication
rule, which is the function
f times g is
differentiable at c.
And the derivative
of the product
is not the product
of the derivatives,
but the prime of c, g of c
plus f of c, g prime of c.
So that's a multiplication rule.
And then, we also have
the quotient rule.
And just like when you need
to divide by something,
you need to assume that
you're never dividing by 0.
If g of x does not
equal 0 for all x in I,
then the function f over
g is differentiable at c.
And the derivative
is the derivative
of the top times the
bottom minus the top
times the derivative of
the bottom over the bottom
squared, [? now ?]
prime g of c squared.
So I'll prove one and two.
Three we'll leave
as an exercise.
So for one, we just
compute that the limit
as x goes to c of alpha f plus g
of x, minus alpha f plus g of c
over x minus c, this is just
by definition alpha times
f of x plus g of x minus alpha
times f of c plus g of c.
And so, this equals the
limit as x goes to c.
And just collecting
terms alpha times alpha
f of x minus f of c times
x minus c, plus g of x
minus g of c over x minus c.
And all of these limits exist.
So this is just a fixed number.
The limit as x goes to c of
this exists and this exists.
So by what we know
about limits, namely
that the limit of the sum
is the sum of the limits.
And then, scalars just
pull out of the limit.
This is equal to alpha times f
prime of c plus g prime of c.
So that's the proof
of the first one.
For the proof of the
second one, we'll
use the fact that
a function which
is differentiable at a point
is also continuous at a point.
So since g is differentiable
at c, it is continuous at c.
I.e.
limit as x goes to c of
g of x equals g of c.
Now we compute the
limit as x goes
to c of f times g
of x minus f of c
times g of c over x minus c.
Now what I'm going to
do is add and subtract
f of c times g of x.
So this I can write
as the limit as x
goes to c of f of x, minus f of
c over x minus c, times g of x.
Plus now, f of c times g of x
minus g of c over x minus c.
And again, so this limit
as x goes to c exists.
This is just the
derivative of f at c.
And we noted that since
g is differentiable at c,
g is also continuous
at c, meaning the limit
as x goes to c of g
of x equals g of c.
This is just a constant f of c.
This goes to g prime of c.
So all these limits exist.
And therefore, we
get that this is
equal to f prime of c times g
of c plus f of c, g prime of c.
And three, I'll
leave as an exercise.
Again, you'll write out--
you'll add and
subtract something
to f of x over g of x
minus f of c over g of c
and use the fact that
differentiability at a point
implies continuity, and
just evaluate the limits.
So I'm going to stop
with these two rules.
I don't know why I called
it the multiplication rule.
It's called the product rule--
well, multiplication and
product are the same thing.
But we also have the
chain rule, which
requires a little more care
to prove than what we've
done so far for these rules.
So suppose I have two intervals.
And then I have a function
g going from I1 to I2,
f going from I2 to
R. And suppose g
is differentiable at c, and f
is differentiable at g of c.
Then the function f of g,
function goes from I1 to R.
This is differentiable at c.
And the derivative
equals f prime of g of c
times g prime of c.
So what's the basic idea?
Again, so this is basic idea
is that we write the difference
quotient, g of x minus f of g of
c over x minus c as f of g of x
minus g, f at g
of c times over g
of x minus g of c times g of
x over g of c times x minus c.
And let x go to c,
and then we'll pick up
the derivative of g here at c.
And right here, this is f of
something converging to g of c.
And so, this should be
like f prime of g of c.
But the only problem with
really writing this down
is that there could be points
where g of x equals g of c.
And then, I'm dividing by 0.
That's not allowed.
So writing this
expression is meaningless.
But we're going to do
something like this in spirit,
where at least when g of
x does not equal g of c,
this thing kind of
equals this thing.
That's the basic idea.
So to implement
this strategy, let's
introduce some notation and
a few auxiliary functions.
So first off, the function
we're interested in taking
the derivative f of g,
let me call that h of x.
Because I don't want to have
to keep writing f of g of x.
Let's call it d.
This will be the point g of c.
So we want to show
then that h prime of c
exists, and it's equal to f
prime of d times g prime of c.
Just in this
notation I've set up.
So now, let me define some
auxiliary functions u of y.
This is going to be essentially
the difference quotient of f,
except at a certain point.
So this is f of y
minus f of d over y
minus d when y does not equal
d so that this is meaningful.
And then, f prime of
d when y equals d.
And then, v of x--
so this is going to play the
role of that first expression
I wrote up there, f of g
of x minus f of g of c.
And then, v of x,
this will be g of x
minus g of c, x minus c
when x does not equal c,
and g prime of c
when x equals c.
Now, essentially
what do we have here?
Then if I look at f
of y minus f of d,
this is equal to u of y
times y minus d, always.
Because if y does not equal
d, then I divide over,
and I get u of y,
then I get f of y
minus f of d on the left-hand
side over y minus d.
And that's equal to
u of y by definition.
And then, when y equals d, I get
0 here, and I get 0 over here.
So that's clear.
And also, the same here,
g of x minus g of c
equals v of x minus
[INAUDIBLE] times x minus c.
So we have these
two expressions.
And one more thing
I want to note
is that u and v are
continuous at y equals
d and x equals c respectively.
So note that v of y
is continuous at d,
and v of x is continuous at c.
So let's look at
the proof of that.
We just need to show that the
limit as y goes to d of v of y
equals v of d.
So compute the limit as
y goes to d of v of y.
Now, when we look
at limits, remember,
we're not allowed
to put y equals
d in the expression
for this limit.
We're always looking at points
y close to d but not equal to d,
is what I'm saying.
And so, therefore, when y is
near d, and not equal to d,
v of y is given by--
I should-- this should--
I should have written
u here, sorry, u.
So we're looking at y near
d, but not equal to d.
And therefore, it's
given by this expression.
So this is the
limit as y goes to d
of f of y minus f
of d over y minus d.
And this is just the definition
of the derivative of f at d.
So remember, d is g of c.
So f is differentiable there.
And this is by
definition u of d.
So this function u is
continuous at y equals d.
And similarly, the limit as
x goes to c of u of x, v of x
equals v of c, which
is g prime of c.
So now we're going to combine
what I've written here
to finish the proof.
So in h of x minus
h of c, this is
equal to f of g of
x minus f of g of c.
And this is equal to u of g of
x times g of x minus g of c.
This is from this relation here.
So we'll call this one
star, this one double star.
This is by star.
And now, I use the second
relation, double star,
to write g of x minus g of c
equals v of x times x minus c.
And therefore, the
limit as x goes
to c of h of x minus h
of c, or x minus c, this
is equal to the
limit as x goes to c
of u of g of x times v of x.
Now, u is continuous at g
of c, g is continuous at c.
And we proved that
the composition
of two continuous
functions is continuous.
So this equals u of g of c.
And v of x, we've
proven already.
That limit is v of c.
And u of g of c, so
this is d, remember,
in the notation we had earlier.
And therefore, that
equals f prime of g of c.
Remember, g of c was
d, times g prime of c.
So to go from this
point to this point,
we use the fact that
u is continuous at c,
which we proved.
u is continuous at g of c,
which we proved over there.
And that g is continuous at c.
And therefore, the composition
of two continuous functions
is continuous at that point
to arrive at this guy.
But again, the
whole basic idea was
to be able to write
the difference
quotient as a product of what
looks like the difference
quotient of f times the
difference quotient of g.
But you have to be
careful, because g of x
could equal g of
c, in which case
you're dividing by 0 in this
basic idea we had up there,
which is not allowed.
But you get around it by
using these functions which
equal what you want as long
as you're not dividing by 0,
basically.
So that wraps it up for basic
properties of the derivative.
And now, we're going to
move on to trying to prove
the mean value theorem--
the Alfred of this Batman tale.
But first, in order
to prove this,
we'll need a result about
the derivative in relation
to certain relative minimum
and relative maximum.
So let me first define
what this means.
Let S be a subset of R, f
be a function from S to R.
We say f has a
relative max at c in S.
If there exists
a delta positive,
such that for all x in S, x
minus c is less than delta,
then f of x is less
than or equal to f of c.
So the picture
here, and then let
me state that there's
analogous definition
of relative min at c.
You just take this
entire definition
and flip the inequality.
That's the definition
for relative min.
So what this means
pictorially, so remember,
we had this notion of
absolute min and absolute max.
An absolute max at a point
c means at every other point
in S, f of x lies below f of c.
Here we're just saying, as long
as you're close to the point c,
then you lay below f of c.
So let's say our function
looks something like that.
So then, let's say we're
at this point here.
So this would be absolute
max, because the graph
of the function sits below
the value of the function
at this point for all x
in this interval a, b.
And then, here at this point,
we would have an absolute min,
because the rest of--
because the graph
of the function
sits above that point for
all x in this interval.
But now, if I go
to this point, say,
this would be a relative
max, because why?
If I look at an interval--
small interval around it,
and I look inside
this interval--
there's too many
dashed lines going on.
So I'm going to erase this.
Yeah, I'm just going to
do away with the dash.
If I zoom in on just this
one piece of the graph,
then at this point,
the graph sits
below this point inside
this little vertical strip.
So this guy would
be a relative max.
And then similarly,
at this point here,
maybe it's-- let me--
so you can really see
what the graph is.
I should have brought
different colors.
At this point, we
have a relative min.
Because nearby points sit
above the value of the function
evaluated at this point.
So relative max means
nearby points f sits below
that f evaluated at that point.
And relative min is
the other way around.
So I don't think
we need to belabor
the point of what relative
min relative maxes are.
I think that's pretty clear.
So the theorem is the following.
If f from a, b has a relative
min or max at a point
c strictly inside this closed
interval, in the open interval
a, b, then and f is
differentiable at c, then
f prime of c equals 0.
And this is kind of
clear from this picture,
although this might look
more like a sawtooth,
but it shouldn't, that
the tangent at this point
is horizontal.
And the tangent at this
point is horizontal,
which just is the expression
that we're just expressing
that f prime of c equals 0.
Because f prime of c is supposed
to be the slope of the tangent.
So the idea of the proof is--
and we'll do it
for relative max.
Relative min you get
by taking minus f.
So we'll do it for suppose f
has a relative max at c in a, b.
Then so I'm just going
to draw a picture
to illustrate why
this is the case, so
or why what I'm about
to say is the case.
So we have a, b, we have c.
Then there exist delta
positive, say delta one,
such that two things are true.
x or c minus delta 1 c plus
delta 1 is contained in a, b.
Two, for all x in c minus
delta 1, c plus delta 1,
f of x is less than
or equal to f of c.
So delta 1 is chosen
as the minimum of--
so maybe let me not
call it delta one,
let me just call it delta.
So first off, you know
that a, b, open interval,
this is an open set which we've
encountered in the assignments.
So you can find a
delta so that delta 0,
say, so that this
interval centered
at c is contained in a, b.
Now, since f has a relative
maximum at this point,
there exist another
delta 1, say,
so that if I'm
inside that interval,
then f of x is less
than or equal to f of c
for all x in that interval.
And I choose delta to be the
minimum of these two deltas.
And then I will
have a chosen delta
so that c minus delta
c plus delta is--
so here, this one is--
and then delta 0 shows them
so that that is contained.
So I choose the minimum
of these deltas.
And this is the delta I
take for this statement.
So now, the way we get
that the derivative is 0
is, we're going to approach
c from above and from
below and use the fact
that we have a relative max
to show that the derivative is
both bigger than or equal to 0
and less than or equal to 0.
So let xn be c minus--
how did I write this--
delta over 2n, which is in
the interval c minus delta c
for all n.
Then what do we know?
xn, the limit as n
goes to infinity of c minus
delta over 2, n converges to c.
So the derivative at c
is equal to the limit
as n goes to infinity
of f of x sub n minus f
of c over x sub n minus c.
Now, what do we note?
So x sub is in
this interval here,
which is contained in
this interval here.
And therefore, f of
x sub n is always
less than or equal to f of c.
So what's on top is always
less than or equal to 0.
Now, x sub n is
always less than c.
So this thing on bottom
is also less than 0.
And therefore, something
that's less than
or equal to 0 on top over
something that's less than 0
on bottom must be bigger
than or equal to 0.
So that's approaching
c from the left.
If we approach c from
the right, delta over 2n
which is contained in c, c
plus delta for all n, then
xn converges to c.
And if we look at f
prime of c, again, this
is equal to limit as
n goes to infinity
of f of y sub n minus f
of c over y sub n minus c.
Again, f of c is a
relative maximum.
So this thing on top is still
less than or equal to 0.
And the thing on
bottom though, is now
since y sub n is bigger
than c, this is positive.
So something on top is negative,
something on top is positive.
So the limit must be negative.
So we've just shown
f prime of c is
both bigger than or equal to 0.
And that it's also less
than or equal to 0.
And therefore, the derivative
is 0 at this point.
And again, the proof
for a relative minimum
is very similar, except
that inequality flips signs.
And therefore, you would
get this is less than
or equal to 0, this one would
be bigger than or equal to 0.
But you still get f prime of
c is bounded between 0 and 0.
So at a point where we have
a relative minimum strictly
inside the interval, the
derivative must be 0.
And the fact that it happens
strictly inside the interval
is important.
This is not necessarily
true if the relative max
or relative min
happens at an endpoint.
Think of f of x
equals x on 0, 1.
Then it has a absolute minimum
at 0, absolute maximum at 1,
and the derivative is 1
at both points, not 0.
So this is only
for relative min,
relative maxes
that occur inside--
strictly inside the interval
that the function is defined on
and where it's differentiable.
So now, we have Rolle's
theorem, which is essentially
the mean value theorem rotated.
We'll get the mean value
theorem from Rolle's theorem.
And which states the following,
let f be from a, b to R,
be continuous.
So it's continuous at every
point in a, b, differentiable
at every point inside of a, b.
It could be differentiable
at the endpoints.
That's fine.
But it has to be differentiable
on the open interval a, b.
If f of b, a equals
f of b equals 0,
then there exists a point c
in the open interval a, b--
and this is important--
such that f prime of c equals 0.
And what's the what's the
picture that goes with this?
I'm sure you've seen it before.
We draw a function that looks
kind of like sine or cosine.
But anyways, function
which is 0 here, 0 here.
Then there has to exist a point
where the tangent is vertical.
In fact, here it can occur
at two different points.
But something
that's already kind
of giving the game away as
far as how we'll prove this
is, let's look at where
the function takes
a maximum and a minimum.
That is the heart of the proof.
And why can we--
why does it even
have an absolute maximum
or absolute minimum?
So I guess I didn't
say this over there
when I discussed relative
min and relative max.
But an absolute maximum is
also a relative maximum.
And absolute minimum is
also a relative minimum.
So let me make this-- this
is kind of a late remark.
Absolute max is a relative
max, absolute mins
is a relative min.
So this picture is kind of
given the game away already.
Let's look at where the
function takes a max and a min.
And why does f take
a max or a min?
It's because f is continuous
on this closed and bounded
interval.
This is something we proved when
we were discussing continuity,
the min max theorem.
So let's give the proof.
Since f is continuous on a,
b, f achieves a relative max
at some point c1 in a, b, and
relative min at c2 in a, b.
If there exists an x--
also.
If of f of c1 is positive,
then what can you say?
Well, c1 cannot be
one of the endpoints,
because at the endpoints, f
of a equals f of b equals 0.
This implies c1 is
in the open interval
a, b, which implies by the
previous theorem, f prime
of c1 equals 0.
So here you-- c equals c1.
If I'm at the minimum now,
and this is less than 0,
then again, this implies that
c2 is in the open interval a,
b, which implies since f has
a minimum at c2, f prime of c2
equals 0 by the
previous theorem.
And therefore, we
could take c equals c2.
If-- now, this is two cases--
f of c1, if either f of c1
is positive or f of
c2 is less than 0,
then we have the result. If f of
c1 is less than or equal to 0,
is less than or
equal to f of c2,
now remember, f
achieves a max that c1.
F achieves a min at c2.
And therefore, this
should always be less than
or equal to this.
If the max and the min--
so first off, I want
to make sure I'm
getting my logic correct here.
So rather than state it this
way, let's do it like this.
So in terms of the
picture here, this
would be c1, c2, where we
achieve a max and a min.
Then in the final case
that f of c1 and then, so
this is the max.
0 is equal to f
evaluated at a point.
Then-- all right.
So let me go back to what I
was going to say a minute ago.
So in the last case, that f of
c1 is less than or equal to 0
is less than f of c2.
Now, remember, this is the
min, this is the max of f.
So this should always
sit above f of c2.
So that implies that f
of c1 equals f of c2.
And therefore, the max
and min equal each other.
Which implies for all x
and a, b, since f of c1
is the minimum, or
f of c2 is the--
so I started off with something
here, there, and in between,
which implies for all x in
a, b, f of x equals f of c2.
So that means f is constant.
And we know what the derivative
of a constant function is.
It's just 0.
So we could take--
say, the midpoint.
And that's the end.
Sorry that I kind of fumbled
through that for a minute,
but--
OK.
So for any function which
is 0 at the endpoints,
there has to be a point in
between where the function is--
the derivative of the
function equals 0.
Now, again, we should come
back to when we see a theorem,
we should pick it
apart a little bit
to see what's
necessary, what's not.
We had these two
hypotheses coming in,
that if the function is
continuous and differentiable
on this open interval a,
b, are these necessary?
So for example, let's
say I have the function--
if I look at the function 1
minus the absolute value of x.
So at minus 1, 1, 1, this
is a continuous function
on minus 1, 1.
And f of minus 1
equals f of 1 equals 0.
But there is no point where
f prime of c equals 0.
What hypothesis did I leave
out for this function?
The fact that it's--
the hypothesis that it's
differentiable at every point
in between.
This function is
not differentiable.
But there's no point where
the derivative equals 0.
So this example tells
you that the hypothesis
that the function
is differentiable
on the interval
minus 1, 1, or a, b,
is necessary for the
theorem to be true.
That's what I'm getting at.
Now, the other hypothesis
that the function
is continuous on the closed
interval is also necessary.
Let's say I look at--
and this is pretty easy to
come up with a counter-example,
if I don't assume that.
Let's take the
function which is--
the function that's x minus
1 for x not equal to minus 1,
and 0 for x equal to minus 1.
So does is this
function look like?
So this function here is
differentiable on minus 1, 1,
f of minus 1 equals
f of 1 equals 0.
But again, there's no
point c in minus 1, 1 so
that f prime of c equals 0.
Because the derivative in
between minus 1, 1 is just 1.
So both of these
hypotheses, that f
is continuous on the closed
interval and differentiable
on the open interval, are
necessary for this theorem
to be true.
If you drop either
of those hypotheses,
then the theorem is false.
So let's rotate this
picture here and arrive
at the mean value theorem.
Let f from a, b to
R be continuous.
So it's continuous on the closed
interval a, b, differentiable
on a, b.
Then there exists a c
in the open interval
a, b such that f prime of c--
let me write it this way--
f of b minus f of
a times b minus a.
So why do I refer to it as a
rotated picture and shifted
version of Rolle's theorem?
So there's a, b.
Here's f of a, f of b.
And let's say that's
how the function looks.
Now, the slope of the line
connecting f of b to f of a
is exactly f of b minus f of a.
So the slope of that line
is f of b minus f of a.
And what we're stating is
that there's a point c,
so that the tangent at that
point is parallel to that line,
has the same slope as the line
connecting f of b to f of a.
So this theorem really does
reduce to Rolle's theorem.
So let me define a
function g from a, b
to R, which satisfies the
hypotheses of Rolle's theorem
and will give us what
we want, basically.
So g of x equals f
of x minus f of b,
plus f of b minus f of a over
b minus a times b minus x.
Basically, what this
function g does is,
it takes the function
now and rotates it,
and shifts it down, so that f--
these two points then
coincide and give you 0.
Then g is continuous on
the closed interval a, b.
Why?
Because it's a sum of two
continuous functions on a, b.
f of x is continuous on a, b.
And this is just a constant.
That's just a constant.
This is a polynomial.
So g is continuous on a, b,
and differentiable on a, b,
again, because f is.
F is differentiable on
the open interval a, b.
This part is
differentiable everywhere
so the sum of two differentiable
functions is differential.
So g of x is
differentiable on a, b.
So continuous on a, b and
And since I said, we're
going to use Rolle's theorem,
let's compute g of a.
This is equal to f
of a minus f of b,
plus f of b minus f of a, over
b minus a, times b minus a.
That cancels with that.
Minus f of b
cancels with f of b.
f of a cancels with minus
f of a, and we get 0.
And then, g of b, this
is even easier to see.
If I just stick
this in, this is f
of b minus f of b plus f of b
minus f of a, over b minus a,
b minus b.
And this also equals 0.
So g of a and g of b are 0.
The function is continuous
on the closed interval.
It's differentiable
on the open interval.
And therefore, by
Rolle's theorem--
I think there's supposed to
be some sort of accent over O,
but I can't remember, and
I've forgotten it already.
By Rolle's theorem, there
exist a point c in a, b, such
that 0 is equal to g prime
of c, which is equal to--
we take g and actually
compute what the derivative is
at c, is equal to f prime of c.
That's a constant
derivative of that is 0.
This times this, the derivative
of x evaluated at c just
gives me minus f of b minus
f of a, times b minus a.
And that's it.
0 is equal to f prime
of c minus what we want.
We move that to the other side,
multiply through by b minus a,
and we're done.
So some first very
nice applications
of the mean value
theorem, which I
think you learned from
calculus are the following.
Let f from I to R
be differentiable,
meaning it's differentiable at
every point in the interval I.
Then we have two conclusions.
f is increasing, meaning
we recall what that means,
for f to be increasing, that
means that if x is less than y,
this implies f of x is less
than or equal to f of y.
This is equivalent
to for all x in I,
f prime of x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
So remember, f prime
is the rate of change.
If the rate of change
is always non-negative,
then f has to be growing.
But this says, f is decreasing,
meaning x less than y
implies f of x is bigger
than or equal to f of y.
This is equivalent to since
a function is increasing
if and only if minus
f is decreasing,
this inequality should flip.
So I'm going to do increasing--
decreasing follows from number
one by taking minus f.
So how much time do I have?
I still have time.
So suppose first that f prime
of x is always non-negative.
Let a, b be in I.
[SNEEZES] Excuse me.
We now want to show f of a is
less than or equal to f of b.
Then f is continuous on
this smaller interval a, b.
Why?
Because f is differentiable
at every point in I.
And therefore, it is
continuous at every point in I.
So in particular on this smaller
interval, and differentiable
on a, b, which implies
there exists a c in a, b--
So by the mean value
theorem, such that f
of b minus f of a equals f
prime of c times b minus a.
And now, since the derivative
is always non-negative
and b minus a is positive, this
is bigger than or equal to 0.
I.e.
if a b minus f of a is
bigger than or equal to 0.
So we prove in one direction.
We've proven that if you
like that the function's
derivative being non-negative
implies that the function is
increasing.
So now let's prove the
opposite direction.
So suppose f is
increasing and c is in I.
Let xn be a sequence in I,
such that xn converges to c.
And one of two things holds.
And either let's say, a,
all n xn is less than c,
or b, all n xn is bigger than c.
And we can always find such
a sequence given a point
C in the interval I.
So if I, so let's say,
it's a closed interval.
And c is in here.
Then we can find a sequence
xn converging to c,
approaching c from the left.
If c is one of the
endpoints, then we
can find a sequence from I
approaching c from the right.
That's b.
And the same thing
if c is over here we
can find a sequence approaching
c, strictly from the left.
So there always exists
such a sequence.
Always exists.
And this is because,
I is an interval.
And if the sequence satisfies
case a, and we look at f prime,
then we get that f
of xn is less than
or equal to f of c for all n.
And let me in fact write this
a little bit differently.
Since-- so here we're
using that f as increasing.
Since f is increasing,
which implies
for all n, f of xn minus f
of c over x of n minus c--
now, this thing on top is
negative. xn is less than c.
So this thing on the
bottom is also negative.
And therefore, this
thing is, positive--
non-negative, I mean.
And therefore, the limit
must also be negative.
But that limit is just a
derivative evaluated at c.
And case b is kind of similar.
I mean, not kind of, it is.
In case b, we get that
for all n, f of xn,
now, since x tends
to the right of c--
let me write it this way.
This minus f of c is
bigger than or equal to 0,
which implies that
f prime of c, which
is the limit as n goes
to infinity of f of xn
minus f of c over xn minus c.
What's on top is non-negative.
And what's on bottom
is non-negative,
because xn is bigger than c.
So bigger than 0, bigger
than 0, bigger than 0.
Thus in either
case, we get that f
prime of c is bigger
than or equal to 0.
And therefore, we've proven
that the derivative is always
non-negative.
So that's one.
And two, f is
decreasing if and only
if the function minus f is
increasing, which by what
we've done from part one is if
and only if minus f prime of x
is bigger than or equal to
0 for all x in I. And then,
multiplying through by this
minus 1 gives me number two.
And so, let me make one last--
I know it's taboo to
write on the back part.
But I'm going to do it anyways.
We have the very simple
theorem which now follows.
Let f from I to R
be differentiable,
then f is constant.
So f of x equals f of
y for all x and y in I,
if and only if the
derivative is identically 0.
So f is constant if
and only if f is both
increasing and decreasing.
Because it satisfies the
equality sign in both of those.
And by what we've done now,
this means for all x in I,
if prime of x is bigger
than or equal to 0, and--
that's for the
increasing part-- f prime
of x is less than or equal to 0.
And therefore, this
is equivalent to f
prime of x equals 0.
So we'll stop there.